[Music]
that's right everyone just because I'm
redoing my bathroom doesn't mean meme
stops still got to review them you're
welcome
hello let's do this say it with me
puffer fish eating carrot puffer fish
eating carrot that's right
this video that was uploaded earlier
this year it's me mic question just who
you are as a person let's just watch it
oh my god why uh tough person 2019 this
video has to be so confused why would
you feed a puffer fish you care I don't
understand why did why I don't
understand this video is so annoying is
it me or is it kind of hot in here
like when puffer fish went ah you know I
felt that now there's a bunch of memes
around this purpose is the one where
their girlfriend is in the window epic
meme epic be quiet I'm trying to eat I
think what makes this meme so great it's
just that it's so relatable and watch
that puffer fish eat that carrot and I
go ha ha ha
I do that I eat pufferfish carrot
even better why does it eat
I can't this video should be legal
illegal another me me and Marty I'm I
write my second never stopped me from
watching puffer fish damn the effort
people spend on this why haha okay
alright this is the best one the
Minecraft edit it's so good although I
do kind of Miss that sounds but why why
pufferfish carrot why that's another me
Oh God Oh nope it puffer fish get out of
there fast I'm not gonna show the video
but that apparently for whatever reason
the chef fed the puffer fish a carrot as
a last meal before serving it I would
like to take a silent minute for puffer
fish and everyone to hit FS in the chat
Thank You powerful fish for the memes
you will not be forgotten I forgot to
rate a puffer fish meme gets of course
10 immortalized live forever in our
hearts 10 you get a 10 baby Yoda was
announced and oh my God he's so cute
low-key kinda want to feed baby Yoda a
carrot not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie
gamers a leader Yoda I'll lead baby Yoda
I will there's listen there's a stigma
against eating baby Yoda's and I'm 4-1
and happy to break it okay I'll happily
be the first one to eat a baby Yoda and
tell you it tastes yeah delicious
everyone be like oh baby you were so
cute I'd be like does it taste good
question mark you know I'm saying
everyone just love baby yo that my god
wait what is this when your dad asked
you to help with something and he
doesn't tell you what to do so you just
stand there like oh my god haha I do
that this is so funny
fourth grader when I was in first grade
fourth graders now this is so relatable
why would they were so scary
like they're all dumb little kids I can
beat them up if I want to I couldn't do
or do not there is no try
boomer okay listen here little [ __ ] oh
my god we got a new boomer versus Zoomer
template actually like that one and you
know what he is cute
obviously obviously guys like come on I
wouldn't eat a baby yoda unless it was
cooked first properly maybe marinated
okay maybe I wouldn't eat baby Yoda but
I would eat the baby grinch
I'm not gonna lie listen Sigma again I'm
happy to be the first one to eat the
baby grinch someone's gotta try it
someone's got to try it you don't think
it was weird to eat cows in the
beginning go do you think people went
they probably don't taste good and then
they ate baby cow and they're like broad
this is good and I'm like okay cool I'll
be the first I'll be the first baby Yoda
zero it's garbage let's get real here
next name I'm telling my kids this was
the Apollo 1 crew I wonder if my parents
lied to me about something like that no
I wouldn't fall for it I'm a stupid
child this has become a meme for
whatever reason to lie about it gonna
tell my kids this is Obama I'm gonna
tell my kids this is Jana and Yoko
that's so nice gonna tell my kids this
is Kurt Cobain I mean wait isn't it
gonna tell my kids this is BTS my god
gotta tell my kids this is Bill Gates I
mean that's just accurate I'm gonna tell
my kids this was Obama okay alright
whatever you want to do you gotta tell
my kids in this is just intruder okay
that's good that's good I like that I
can see there's meme popping off it's
still pretty early so therefore I will
give it at zero there's really why am I
even doing this episodes so bad you do
things that are typically considered
inappropriate or immoral but the author
consider them to be good or maybe he
doesn't I can tell when these are ironic
and when they aren't because my brain is
so small this is correct statement why
does this look like me Jesus Christ even
the camera angle this is fate I need
more of that Chad should
I don't really have are you winning son
yes this is such another car which mean
Jesus Christ help me please make good
memes again yes
Kudo no order for whatever reason this
is a meme to kind of show oh you do this
yes basically that's the meme summarize
Virginia hanging out with little boys in
spandex I see yes you got a problem with
a okay example I'll make one of me she
would eat baby Yoda yes yeah yeah I
would
hey you have enemy profile pic low yeah
yeah I do have anyway profile pic yeah
my peepee very big what what are you
going to do you know that no one that
has enemy profile pic looks like oh wait
I have anime profile pic oh oh no oh no
I forgot that I had anybody profile pic
oh the new PewDiePie headphones are
finally here I'm so glad I can finally
wear these first things first
these have cooling gel infused cushions
very underrated it feels so good I don't
know about you when you wear headphones
for too long it gets really
uncomfortable and hot this feels so nice
I love it
I haven't plugged it in bang this will
lit up as well alright first up let's
talk design obviously please look
amazing got the classic PDI design
PewDiePie logo on the inside this lit
sup very epically they have eraser hi
persons even if the game isn't
pre-programmed to have positional
information you can tell where people
are in the game it still works from 20
to 200 Hertz of lifelike sensational
sounds this is the top of the top 2.4
gigahertz wireless audio no like high
fidelity 360 degrees positional audio
natural and lifelike experience these
are really cool and I hope you guys want
to join them as well check it out they
retail for $1.99 you can find them at
racer calm the link in this in the
description let's get on with the video
you hate Sam yes this is like that my
name is Jeff equivalent of answering a
question I don't understand I becoming
two boomer for memes I think that's the
problem
another zero three in a row gamers we
truly did it this is what a time to be
alive time for some more important news
hashtag game freak light oh my god a
game development company lied about what
the game was gonna be this is unheard of
how can this happen
so there's a bunch of controversy about
the new Pokemon game saying that they
are reusing models from different
Pokemon games even though allegedly the
studio said we want to focus on high
quality animations and make the game
more expressive overall wow it looks so
expressive so much in the game I think
they also said that they were gonna cut
some of the pokemons from in like
they're just gonna be less pokemons in
this one because they wanted to make
them good I guess but in reality they
just took the exact same model wow I
mean I guess it's not that big of a deal
to reuse animations and stuff like that
but if you lie about it that's a
different story I mean look at this
embarrassing you know what Pokemon like
game didn't lie to their audience that's
right Beauty pipes pixel Inc we didn't
steal any animations your stinky
brainers download now now I don't play
Pokemon because I'm not a child
[Laughter]
[Music]
sixty dollars for this game do you know
how much speed price pixel incomes you
can download million it's free is what
I'm trying to say free free game with
hand-drawn animations okay or you want
this crap you tell me okay here's some
more examples
guys we couldn't add enough Pokemon said
we just really needed to make it unique
and make a high quality as possible
Brock can I copy your homework yeah just
make sure like no one notices okay
just make it a little bit different
there are of course the contrarians
saying people are just nitpicking people
are just being freaky sneaky peeky
pokemon sword and shield versus ocarina
of time Wow pokemons stole directly the
texture pack from ocarina of time
unbelievable
why does the game look so bad gene says
this has led to a lot of fans being very
angry I don't really care I just like
being part of an angry mob really just
got a three point three user score not
happy people are very angry as they
should as they should these are the
things that truly matter 450 Pokemon
were cut for these high quality and it
may shed wow that looks so good fact
criticism is not toxicity in fact having
standards for a sixty product is not
being entitled Game Freak lied about
models being remade supporting or
praising these Pokemon tile is fine but
pertaining Game Freak can't possibly do
better is not oh the whole game freezes
if you go on the ladder okay so
apparently that gif is from illegally
stream gameplay and they have explained
that NPCs do indeed freeze when climbing
ladder
ok game freeze reaction tell you guys
complaining about the new Pokemon game
wait Joker's getting a sequel Oh freak
yeah that's awesome Pokemon meme gets
another zero Wow incredible job everyone
yeah listen I had lack of sleep Maya
kept me up all night her stomach was
growling next meme
this is an older meme but it's still
good it's from the release of the color
duty trailer when he goes Bravo six
going dark
epic when you're beating your meat in
the bathroom and you hear footsteps near
the door stop over six going dark
stand up too fast my brain robber six
going so bad when you're new on reddit
and learn that dark mode is superior
Bravo six
going dark how do you not know that
Jesus Christ that's pathetic when you're
pooping for so long
the automatic bathroom lights turns on
Bravo six going down that's good I like
that whenever that happens I never flail
my arm
I just keep squeezing so hard that the
light just comes back on when you
decline Google to know your location
Bravo six going down when you enable
incognito mode Bravo six go in dark FBI
be like where he go he went dark can't
track him mom walking towards my room
six-year-old me later in 2010 the DEA's
promised six going back while I was
having the Nintendo DS underneath your
pillow just like the greatest thing of
all time because back in the day when
when you had Game Boy you still needed a
little light because they didn't have an
internal light source there's a there's
a boom we're talking okay but the D is
you could still play it in your bed
without in light and it was the best
Professor Layton
so again are we on the ground they bleed
like Bravo six go and dark going dark
meme gets you guessed it ten out of ten
there's also been this meme floating
around the everyone pointing but let's
get real it's not that interesting I'm
not gonna sit here and waste your time
but any more mediocre terrible memes but
this is this was this week apparently do
better next one gamers I did like this
one though when old people would stop
saying games make kids violent oak hey
boomer come on that's funny when he meet
a bad girl in Japan but she doesn't have
pixelated
I'll never forgive the Japanese how dare
you what is this
that's funny come on that's funny Oh see
you like math name every number damn
that is the equivalent of savagery all
right hope you guys enjoyed this strange
epically episode a meme review clearly I
feel very strange recording in this room
so I hope this was fine anyway it's fast
and I'll see you guys tomorrow and I'm
still gonna be in this room god help me
we're all excited about the new game
that's coming out and I can't wait to
play it it starts with the letter P can
you guess what it is here the pie pick
ceiling of course what you thought it
was Pokemon dumbass you stinky brainer
you